[Musique]
Monsieur Louis Boudreau vous êtes pour
la première fois en France c'est plus
précisément à Rennes pour participer au
festival au 3è festival de des arts
traditionnels et vous êtes un violonneux
québécois or pour un français le mot
violonneux a une petite résonance
passéiste est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire l'importance qui était le
violonneux au Québec dans le Québec
d'autrefois ce que je vois vous parler
là ça veut dire à peu près 50 ans avant
aujourd'hui là en effet le temps où je
faisais ma jeunesse un viux c'était
l'élément principal dans dans un village
pu il n'avait pas tous les
villages il pouvait pas se faire aucune
fête sans sengager ou avoir un
violonneud même pas engagé ça CIT ROR
qui était engagé faisait toujours ça par
plaisir c'était un spécialiste quand
même ah oui toujours un spécialiste puis
il pouvait avoir dans la région de
chouimi disons pour un affaire de 200
200000 habitants il pou avoir qure ou C
violonneux qui étent apte à pouvoir
dévertir le monde et c'était le violonux
c'était son métier il ne faisait que ça
ou non non absolument pas il n'avait pas
qui Prati ça pour gagner leur vie à part
du Père Xavier d'aller dont je vous
parlerai au cours du programme oui ça
c'est une exception ça mais il jouit
beaucoup pour les noces aussi les no il
se faisaent pas de voyage de
no plus ou moins
riche la noce pouvait durer un jour 2
jours jusqu'à 6 jours une semaine là cé
des gens les gens riches qui pouvait
durer ça mais c'est toujours le même
violonneux qui durait toute la semaine à
la fin de la semaine il était magané le
GS surtout s'il avait s'il aimait à
prendre un coup pas
mal une chose que personne sait en joint
du violon pour faire danser là on
pourrait boire une tonne de whisky puis
je pense qu'on viendrait pas chaud
parceon à
mesureoui s arrête de jouer mais faut
pas qu'il continue à boire ou il VI Chau
V les viol ne ça ça évoque aussi pour
nous les veillé pendant une veillée de
carnaval par exemple là c'est les jours
gros Val carê tout était observé dans
carê pouroulait pas fumer une
cigaretteen tout le monde faisait
pénitence à por de
moi une veillé ordinaire ça commençait
par jouer aux cartes ça des veillist C à
7h tout le monde éit rendu ah ou qui
veut dire pour vous autres
là
12,6 12 7 oui ouais ça F 12
7 19
tout é rendu pour commcer veill la
vaisselle pr pas
temps il mett à jou
tranill
pasends
8h je
de viol commen àer son viol commen par
jouer pour juste pour
écouter avait des
jeunesement
sorganis autres qui partai commenç à
veiller cette carrée c'est une danse une
danse à qure couples tu sais c'est comme
pa jaune par exemple dans ce
genre cétait cé par individu de la
Gaille puis après ça le tour des
vieux danser BR une contredans là
fallait que sa tout frotter des hommes
comme les femmes quand il était h coup
pass BR joueur de violon prenait B je
suis ça dura 1 heure
record puis ça prenait l'histoire de
prendre un coup le celui-là qui recevait
le son monde pour une veillé
particulière il passait une traite avec
les petits verr d'un 11 et whk c'était
le blanc ça le rouge ben c'était le vent
vous voyez jamais une femme prendre un
un ver de whisky non le blanc était
réservé aux hommes le rouge aux femmes
Aum et quand il avait passé deux fois il
avait fait son devoir là deux fois d'un
grande veillée ah ben on ne buvait pas
beaucoup on dansait plus qu'on ne buvait
chacun ortait sa petite réserve par
exemple les hommes ortai les petites
réserve puis ordinairement il cachait ça
dans crèche des chevaux la en
particulierner au viol il sortait de
temp en temps sortir le flasque un
petitachette puis le violonux il
participait aussi ah ouais les femmes
chaudes on nenvoyait pas ah ouis un cas
particulier ça pouvait se rencontrer
mais cétait mal pour vous donner une
idée d' danse qui pouvait se danser par
les vieux ou aussi bien par les jeunes
aussi tu iras tu voir les filles mon
petit bonhomme ça c'est une danse
favorite des vieux de ce tempsl tu iras
tu voir les filles mon petit bonhomme tu
iras VO les fill oui mon père je ferai
comme vous j'irai les
voir je vous donner musique idée de ce
qui
[Musique]
sinenta
c une grande dan pouvit durer Gard et
c'était les gars et les filles là les
hommes et les femmes dans éta était
capable de frotter pour que
ouais vous parliez tout à l'heure du
carè puis il pas question de fumer une
cigarette pendant le car
c'était donc la société quand même était
quand même bien structurée dans ce sensl
comment le comment les les fêtes là
comment les danses les violeneux vous
étiez pas vu un peu comme le diable
quelque fois par ça oui ilavait moi
j'avais eu cette impression là le
premier parce que le grand Catchi s
image ça se promenit sur table des
familles ça à l'année longue oui oui
puis on était tout bien plus cyant que
le monde en général le sont aujourd'hui
on était élevé de cette façon
là le grand catchismeù j'avais observé
que la page de l'enfer était représenté
par une vierge qui était pleine de
chaînes d'or puis qui était belle àroqué
des yobes à l'entour deelle éta tout
attaché par les poignettes des chaînes
qui dans un S puis le diable sur une
tablette àprès coison là moi je me
faisait une idée Mo dit si c'est ça
l'enfire là j'ai pas envie de de
continuer à jouer du violant c'est
dangereux ça de pas gagner le ciel vous
connaissez des gens qui ont arrêté de
jouer du violon parce que c'était ils
avaient des difficultés euh comme mon
père quand ça a été défendu pour lui de
jouer le bobelo là dernier on finit r là
avec cette histoire de bobelo là c'est
agit des enfants mais l'histoire de
danser cétait parmi d'os une journée pas
pas 5 jour 6 jours qui dans une journée
la journée du mariage puis une fille
pouvait pas se laisser prendre par en
dessous des bras pour souigner là comme
ça fait des canadien
surtout si un gars avait eu badlog
d'aller apprendre en dessour des bras
pour souigner il Fall qu' s'accuse de ça
c'est un péché mortel ça ah en effet à
Radio Canada Montréal appelez-moi lise
je sais pas une fois lise me demande
quelle différence P ben facile à
expliquer quand le garsour des bras de
la fille là il peut avoir tendance peêre
pé ses
accessoires P il peut pas ça ah oui vous
pourriez nous jouer une jig parce que ça
ça para que c'était quand même une danse
sautillante ça sautait ça y allait quoi
ah oui il yait un petit bout du brend là
ça le brend des en cours ça tout un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant Louis boudre que
deviennent les violonnés au Québec en
restent-ils beaucoup que font-ils et
est-ce qu'il y a des jeunes pour prendre
leur lève oui il vont en avoir depuis 5
ou 6 ans là on dirait que beaucoup de
monde surtout les les universités là il
a des équipes oui pour le folklore qui
qui s'organise pour faire des recherches
partout pour tout réquisitionne
ça ils veulent leur mettre ça en
évidence 5 6 ans on s'aperçoit que ça
prend de l'ampleur beaucoup beaucoup
puis des bons violonneux ils vont en
avoir encore mais avec le style que j'ai
moi je suis le seul à représenter le
vieux p cours du lac Saint-Jean qui
était Violu avant mon père céit un oncle
de papa papa av gardé ce style là lui
exclusif puis moi je l'ai pris de papa
je gardeis rien que ça mais su pas amusé
à apprendre d'autres choses qui suit le
moderne là pu oui j'ura été capable mais
ça m'intéressait pas je vois ces
affaires là parce que j'avais la
nostalgie du beau temps que je m'étais
amusé avec mes parents il y a donc dit-
il y a donc des je vais vous demander d'
d'en donner un exemple au violon il y a
donc des des choses des créations qui
qui disparaîtront avec les violonux même
comme si ça faisait partie c'était leur
vie et qui ne pourra pas quand même être
repris par même par les jeunes al là je
peux vous citer quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ça serait le bobelo qui
a été une danse de de gens commun ce
qu'on entend dire par des gens commun
c'est de de bossse réputation là tu sais
ça se dansait par ces gensl mais c'est
venu interdit par l'église puis pour
arrêter ça complètement ils s'en en pris
au joueurs de violon qui qu' communier
si il jou ça faire danser quand ça
serait déclaré ça se déclare toujours il
fait ça fon ça en public mais va pas
continuer à jouer ça lui à 9h fallait
que les enfants aent se coucher il
restait pas enveiller avec le grand
monde puis il y avait le privilège de se
faire jouer leur g il appel ça
puse papa en particulier il était il
aimait B enfants il jouit le RIL des
enfants il a continué d'appeler ça le
RIL des enfants et ben on va écouter une
partie du RIL des enfants parce que
malgré tout c'est une des choses qui qui
vous personnel c'est une chose ou je
suis à près je suis certain d'être le
seul dans province Québec qui a gardé
cette affaire là voilà in ça les quatre
coins mais c'est pas la même chose ils
font le tour du viol on vaescendre allez
voir la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
différence
[Musique]